so two of my favorite action heroes from
the 80s have had movies within like a
two-week period Arnold Schwarzenegger
and now Sylvester Stallone
I enjoy The Last Stand it was fun was
bold to the head a piece of crap like a
trailer made it look like bullet to the
head star Sylvester Stallone as a hitman
of sorts he works with his partner they
do a hit and doesn't exactly go as they
plan they found out they were set up
while they're at a bar Jason Momoa comes
up and stabs his partner to death and
then tries to kill Sylvester Stallone
but fails now Stallone is on a path to
find this guy and the people involved
with the organization that set him and
his partner up along with a cop the guy
from Fast Five I can't quite remember
his name now these two guys set off on a
kind of buddy-cop like adventure to join
adventure it's not really an adventure
lots of blood in this one now as I said
in my intro this trailer really looked
bad it looks so just it looked bad all
the jokes didn't work in the trailer and
I was really dreading seeing this movie
I was surprised though this movie isn't
awful at all I actually had a fair
amount of fun with this movie and I'm
telling you that in all seriousness this
is another movie kind of like The Last
Stand where you can't take it too
seriously although it definitely does
have a more serious vibe than The Last
Stand does and in some ways it's made
much better Walter Hill as a director is
pretty famous for making some pretty
good action movies in the 70s namely the
driver which some have said heavily
inspired Nicolas Winding reference drive
this film does have a very similar CD
city like nightlife quality to it where
there's lots of jazz music in the
background a little film noir ash at
times lots of conversations between
characters and cars and then lots of
bullets to the head and blood spray and
punching and Sylvester Stallone flexing
those veiny muscles of his I gotta say
though dude that guy isn't shape me
maybe dopin but he is in shape for in
his 60s good job my friend also
Christian Slater shows up in this movie
and a bit of a small role but it was
kind of interesting seeing him kind of
fun I liked it from the 90s days you
know true romance Broken Arrow and Jason
Momoa is coming off the abysmal Conan
the Barbarian much better in this film
he doesn't have as much to say he's kind
of an emotionless straight forward to
kick butt all day villain like that's
all he does is kill people and take
names and he does a pretty good job in
this movie
menacing the movie has a pretty nice
score as well the background music to
the movie was nice I liked a lot of the
bar scenes where they had this kind of
light piano music playing it was pretty
cool
but the movie just had a nice tone to it
that I was surprised by and some pretty
good action scenes although a little bit
of shaky-cam is used
you can tell though that it's not
shaky-cam to mask poor stunt work or to
mask poor storytelling it's just it's a
little shaky at times but you can see
that Stallone it's taking a lot of the
hits himself and some of these guys are
gonna knock down pretty hard and I was
pleased with that problems with the
movie there's quite a bit
the acting at times not that great but
you know I mean really is that gonna be
the complaint see this movie comes from
a different era this is a very much late
70s early 80s action film it feels like
that despite the fact there's the
overuse of CGI blood and it's not awful
CGI you can tell but it's not terrible
the script is filled with cliches you
know the damsel in distress the big end
fight it has all the little needed
elements of an action movie and you can
tell you can just see where it's going a
lot you can see okay is gonna happen
it's gonna happen a little predictable
but the movie itself is an entertaining
ride Stallone was actually a lot of fun
in this movie and I really liked his
character I thought he did a pretty good
job in this movie he had a lot of really
good one-liners and this chemistry with
him and the cop was really good and they
actually had a pretty funny buddy cop
relationship and I was truly surprised
by this movie but still it's not the
greatest movie there's nothing about
this movie that is like wow that was
just amazing it's just a fun ride filled
with mindless entertainment I'm gonna
give bullet to the head of be - it's not
a great movie it's not a terrible movie
at all it's just a fun watch and if
you're a fan of Stallone in the eighties
action films I think you'll enjoy it
just like I did thanks a lot for
watching guys and as always if you liked
this review then you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes
you